[Music]
kay is with us in denver colorado hey
kay welcome to the ramsay show
thank you how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's up
i lost my husband seven months ago to
cancer oh my and
yeah and we never
decided whether we were going to
purchase
the home for our three kids or whether
we were going to make a large down
payment for them
and now i'm kind of like what do i do
purchase
your three children are grown and you
wanted to buy them homes as adults is
that what you're saying yep
yep that's what we're saying okay all
right
wow
so you're obviously in a very good
position financially
i
ran into this book in 2009 called total
money makeover
and it just stopped frank's and my
we own
a business and it just stopped our life
and we just turned around and got
ourselves debt free wow
wow
okay
i'm so sorry uh how old was he
he was 64.
going on 46.
i want that on my tombstone
i love him already what a great guy
oh my gosh
and you have three kids and they're all
grown
are they all married
they're all married okay
all right
and um what is your net worth now
uh four million good for you okay
and so you're talking about
buying a house price of what per kid
i'm
i have one in portland so
kind of 500 000 i have one here in the
denver area so another 500 000 and i
have one in minnesota and i think i
could do 300 000.
okay or
500 or whatever if you did just did
so a million five of your
would leave you at two five right
um yeah but that includes my home
yeah so
cash pretty big three million yeah it's
a pretty big hit
cut your cash in half
um
but a million i just got from from him
so in my mind um you know he's paying
for two out of three kids right now
how old and you're how old
57
how old are they the kids what's your
range um 38
36 34.
okay
are you planning to stay in the business
you going to sell the business what's
that paying you
um
i'm planning to stay in the business and
it could pay me
anywhere from
you know like this last year i did i
really didn't work and i made fifty
thousand
um
i'm sure i won't go back like i was so i
don't know 50 to
150 200 000 probably what i could make a
year
but for the last five years we kind of
retired in 2017 um because this cancer
hit four times
and so i would work and
um
that would be our play money we'd take
the kids here or we'd do this or we'd do
that
okay i um love the idea of helping the
kids
and um
uh
but but the pre the caveat has to be
that you're okay first
and um
a million and a half out of
this is
uh
it it's it's it's it's pushing my fear
button a little bit for you
okay
it's not a million and a half out of 11
million it's half your cash
and
so
i'm probably going to do this in two
stages if i'm you
like a max of 300 per kid
and so that uses a third of your cash
not half of your cash right
and
that might buy the one in uh minnesota
or wherever it was the full house i
don't know and to be the down payment
for the other two and then you're you're
working and making 200 and you look up
in your net worth is five million
dollars
five or ten years from now you pay the
other two off
you know
uh so if i was going to buy the kids the
home i was going to keep
i was going to keep it under a trust and
keep i was going to have the house
so they couldn't borrow against it so
they couldn't you know ever get in
trouble
i had a friend that paid paid for his
kids houses and all he asked for was a
letter from each of those kids and their
spouse promising to never borrow a dime
again of any kind and in return you get
a house
and you know you're going through
financial peace and so forth right and
so that's the you know that's the
commitment on their part rather than
trying to protect them from themselves
the best way to protect them from
themselves is not be somebody they need
to be protected from
and so
if they're not if they won't be willing
to commit to not turn around and
mortgage it i don't want to give them
one
so the other um the other piece of this
is i have one that's
good to fair with money one that's fair
and one's fair to terrible
so
and so they you know so you know so
you're gonna have to prove to me that
you're worthy of this by quit being fair
to terrible
because otherwise i'm giving a drunk a
drink i have no desire to
uh give somebody a house that's going to
turn around and it'd be a curse to them
rather than a blessing the whole purpose
of this is to be a blessing
and and i agree and we you know we agree
to that and i understand that but what
if they can't qualify for 300
000. dollar home or 250 000 dollar home
yeah well it may take a little while to
execute all this which will also give
you time to grow some more wealth
no one says you had to do it all today
if they're not ready
okay we started the discussion assuming
i was assuming they were all ready but i
may want to rehab
the behaviors of one of these and get
commitments from the other two and this
might take a year
during which time you're in you know
your money is invested and it's going to
go up
and um
you know because you're probably not
touching any of this you're probably
just going to make enough to live on i
suspect
yeah that's what we've been doing
um
[Music]
one of the things i've learned is that
generosity sometimes is hard work
surprisingly
it's not given some type you're not
giving somebody 20 at the gas pump
surprise and delight you know random
generosity this is 300 000 bucks to
somebody that you love
and that you know you could be doing
harm to if you don't do it right so it's
going to require a process and you're
grieving
and they're grieving
so um yeah
i don't think the husband you're
describing to me is going to give the
kid that's misbehaving with money money
was he that guy was he an enabler no he
wasn't but his biggest pet peeve is all
these kids rent and as you know rent is
crazy right now
that was just his thing i i agree i'm a
real estate guy too i like it i love the
idea of them all having paid for houses
but i want that to be a blessing to them
and that entails them a handling money
well be committing to never borrow money
again otherwise undoes everything that
his
legacy your legacy that you're trying to
do is doing
so i would just let this unfold a little
bit over time here let's give this a
little time you guys continue the
grieving process it takes a little while
to breathe
um you're doing awfully well on the
phone here
thank you for that that's um
because i was about crying just
listening to you um
but the uh um yeah sitting down with
them and going okay guys i don't know
what i'm doing right now but i'm kind of
thinking out here in the near future
uh fall next spring something like that
we need to be talking about doing this
and here's what i'm thinking and here's
my worries and uh here's what i think
i'm going to ask you to do
and y'all start processing that and you
know you can do whatever you want to do
but that's the way we would probably do
it around here
if we were doing it